the sheep are everything
they're my employees they're my
co-workers they're my livelihood
i'm very much
bonded to my animals and i hope they're
bonded to me hope they enjoy working
with me as much as i enjoy working with
them
my name is zach richardson and i'm an
urban shepherd i call myself an urban
shepherd because i guess technically i'm
a shepherd one who
tends a flock of sheep but most of my
projects are in the city
urban grazing is the strategic
use of sheep
to manage overgrown landscapes in an
urban context
right now i have a total of
60 ewes or female sheep
sheep will eat
just about everything
this site has it but every invasive
species that's common in middle
tennessee you know euonymus english ivy
privet honeysuckle japanese honeysuckle
a tree of heaven but they'll eat
all of them
let's say you have an overgrown piece of
property you call me and you tell me
exactly the areas that you're targeting
and then
we load up some sheep on a trailer bring
you a modest flock
and they stay on site until the job is
completed
dougie is
the most important component
uh to my business he's more important
than my truck he's more important than
my trailer
almost more important than the sheep his
job as a border collie instinctively is
to gather the sheep and he loves doing
it you could throw a junior whopper at
him when he's working he wouldn't care
he just wants to keep working that'll do
it
lie down this is not a new concept you
know moving sheep to clear land here in
the city we've forgotten that this is
even possible this is an option
it's deep down in all of us somewhere to
want to watch animals do what they do
we've just kind of been removed from it
it's therapeutic isn't it just watching
sheep
you